[Music]
john's in kansas city hey john welcome
to the ramsey show
thank you sir i appreciate you taking
the call
my wife and i pastor small church and
we've been fpu coordinators and have
trained other people in that
thank you matter of fact i'm not saying
it's for accolades but i uh every time
we marry someone we give them a copy of
the total money makeover and wow write a
note in there to follow the biblical
principles that are in this book and
many of them have gotten debt free
my issue today is
i'm 66
i don't have much money
saved for retirement
we don't make a lot of money like i said
we pastor a small church there's been
times we've had to
skip taking a paycheck uh that kind of
thing my wife does work outside the home
and we're both
uh receiving social security now
so it supplements our income but
um i don't have a lot of money saved
we're just concerned about you know
we're going to have enough money to live
on when it's all said and done
uh we're debt-free except for our house
we don't know a lot of money on that
what do you owe on the house
oh 85 000 on the house and it's worth
600 and how much nest egg have you got
about 30 35
thousand dollars
yes okay
all right and what's your household
income these days
uh we're about seventy thousand dollars
uh including everything okay
um and are both of you planning to stay
in the same uh
work situation for the next few years
yes yeah i i plan to stay here you know
it's uh it's not a career choice with me
it's actually a calling and i appreciate
that
otherwise i
might had something that had a better
look for something and had a better pay
package but it's really it's really not
about that it's about ministering to
people absolutely and this is just where
i'm at
have a great heart and so uh you know
what i would tell you is i got two goals
for you in five years perfect i'm ready
for you get the house paid off and put a
hundred thousand dollars for mutual
funds
okay still not gonna be still not gonna
be enough
but you'll be 71 and you'd have a
hundred and uh
170 approaching two hundred thousand
dollars in there with the growth of the
35 if it's in mutual funds
and um so you'll be approaching 200 000
and i paid for 600 000 house
if you can't make it at least we know
you can sell the house and move to a 400
000 house
well absolutely yeah we've considered
that uh i wouldn't do it today but
that's your fallback plan but if you
could get the house paid off and put 200
away
i think you could make it
well uh i'm we're we're fast tracking
the house we're paying an additional
eighteen hundred dollars a month against
the principal and it looks to pay out in
two and a half years that's perfect
meanwhile meanwhile you got to do more
than that in addition
into retirement because i need to you
get a hundred and five years that's 20
000 bucks that's another 1500 that's
another 1800 a month
okay so i need to be putting another
1800 a way into i just made that number
up pastor i mean i just made it up it's
not it's not a trick number i just was
looking at a 70 000 income
and i thought how much can can we
squeeze out of this turnip
okay okay and i'm thinking there's no
magic to i mean if i could have you have
do have a million when you're retired
i'd do it but i don't see that in the
numbers i'm trying to do something where
you can eat
and still pull this off and get some
margin between you and the wolf
okay okay and so that's reasonable yeah
so if you saved 18 if you saved 1800
that'd be 20 000 you did that for five
years that'd be a hundred thousand plus
it will grow some during that plus your
35 will grow some during that so that'll
bump you pretty close to 200.
okay in your mutual funds and then you'd
have a paid for six hundred thousand
dollar house you're almost a millionaire
at that point
wow i never thought about it like that
yeah awesome well that's a five that's
five more years of working like you're
working now her too
okay perfect
well i just need to get a hold of one of
your elps and help me with the raw thing
i don't really understand all of that so
jump on smart vester smart investor at
ramseysolutions.com and thank you for
your heart
and uh your service
and you know we're just talking about
that a minute ago with parsonages and
it's a little different subject but
uh
gentle big heart call call a god on his
life without a doubt and he's staring
down the barrel of retirement he's got
30 000 bucks in the bank yeah all right
luckily he's got a house he's got a
great do something about it and good
news is he can do something about it
still um it's not gonna be fancy we can
do something about it so the house may
end up being the
answer before it's over but hopefully
not hopefully we can work it through
without selling it if they don't want to
sell it but he even held that with an
open hand you hear that yep guys
spiritual maturity is amazing